each day
i receive a small card in my pocket
that i carry with me my schedule and
shows the number of americans who've
been infected
by or died from coven 19.
today we mark a truly grim
heartbreaking milestone
500 071
dead that's more americans
who have died in one year in this
pandemic
than in world war one world war
ii and the vietnam war combined
that's more lives lost to this virus
than any other nation on earth
but as we acknowledge the scale of this
mass death
in america we remember each person
in the life they lived they're people we
knew
they're people we feel like we knew
read the obituaries and remembrances
the son who called his mom every night
just to check in the father's
daughter who lit up his world
the best friend who was always there
the nurse the nurse and nurses but the
nurse
who made her patients want to live
i was in just in kalamazoo michigan at
the pfizer vaccine manufacturing
facility
there i met a man when i walked in whose
father-in-law was dying of the virus
he was sad i asked if i could call his
father-in-law
he said his father-in-law was too sick
to speak
but then he said but could i pray for
him
could i pray for him we all know someone
fellow americans who live lives of
struggle
purpose and of hope
who talked late in the night about their
dreams
who wore the uniform born to serve
who loved played and always offered a
hand
we often hear people described as
ordinary americans
there's no such thing there's nothing
ordinary about them
the people we lost were extraordinary
they span generations
born in america immigrated to america
but just like that so many of them took
their final breath
alone in america
as a nation we can't accept such a cruel
fate
while we've been fighting this pandemic
for so long
we have to resist becoming numb to the
sorrow
we have to resist viewing each life
as a as a statistic or a blur
or on the news we must do so to honor
the dead
but equally important care for the
living those who left behind
for the loved ones left behind i know
all too well
i know what it's like to not be there
when it happens
i know what it's like when you are there
holding their hands just look in your
eye and they slip away
that black hole in your chest you feel
like you're being sucked into it
the survivors remorse the anger
the questions of faith in your soul
for some of you it's been a year a month
a week a day even an
hour
and i know that when you stare at an
empty chair
around the kitchen table it brings it
all back no matter how long ago it
happened
as if it just happened that moment you
look at an empty chair
the birthdays the anniversaries the
holidays without them
and the everyday things the small things
the tiny things
that you miss the most that scent when
you open the closet
that park you go by they used to stroll
in
that movie theater where you met
the morning coffee you shared together
the bend in his smile a perfect pitch to
her laugh
i received a letter from a daughter
whose father died of covet 19 on easter
sunday last year
she and her children his grandchildren
and her lent this season a season of
reflection and renewal
with heavy hearts unable to properly
mourn she asked me in the letter
what was our loss among so many others
well that's what has been so cruel
so many of the rituals that help us cope
that help us honor those we loved
haven't been available to us
the final rights with family gathered
around
the proper homegoing showered with
stories and love
tribal leaders passing out the final
traditions
of sacred cultures on sacred lands
as a nation we cannot
and we must not let this go on
that's why the day before my
inauguration
at the kova 19 memorial at the
reflecting pool
in the national mall i said to heal to
heal
we must remember i know it's hard i
promise you i know it's hard i remember
but that's how you heal you have to
remember
and it's also important to do that as a
nation
for those who have lost loved ones
this is what i know they're never
truly gone they'll always be part of
your heart
i know this as well and it seems
unbelievable
but i promise you the day will come
and the memory of the loved one you lost
will bring a smile to your lips before
a tear to your eye it will come i
promise you
my prayer for you though is that they
will come
sooner rather than later and that's when
you know
you're going to be okay you're going to
be okay
and for me the way through
sorrow and grief is to find purpose i
don't know how many you've lost
someone a while ago wonder is he or she
proud of me now
this is what they want me to do
i know that's how i feel
we can find purpose
purpose worthy of the lives they lived
i'm worthy of the country we love so
today
i ask all americans to remember
remember those we lost and those are
left behind
but as remember as we all remember
i also ask us to act to remain vigilant
stay socially distant to mask up
get vaccinated when it's your turn
we must end the politics and
misinformations divided families
communities in the country has cost too
many lives already
it's not democrats and republicans who
are dying from the virus
it's our fellow americans it's our
neighbors our friends
our mothers our fathers our sons our
daughters
husbands wives
we have to fight this together as one
people
as the united states of america
that's the only way we're going to beat
this virus i promise you
the only way to spare more pain and more
loss the only way
these millstones no longer mark our
national mourning these milestones i
should say no
no longer mark our national morning
let this not be a story of how far we
fell
but how far we climb back up
we can do this for in this year profound
loss
we've seen profound courage from all of
you
on the front lines i know the stress the
trauma the grief you carry
but you give us hope you keep us going
we remind us that we do take care of our
own
that we leave nobody behind
and while we've been humbled we have
never given up we are
america we can and will do this
in just a few minutes jill and i
kamal and doug will hold a moment of
silence here in the white house
the people's house your house
we ask you to join us
to remember so we can heal
to find purpose in the work ahead
to show that there is light in the
darkness
this nation will smile again this nation
will know sunny days again
this nation will know joy again
and as we do we'll remember each person
we've lost
the lives they lived the loved ones they
left behind
we will get through this i promise you
but my heart aches for you those of you
who are going through it right now
may god bless you all particularly those
who've lost someone
god bless you
oh
you